let me tell you about the day I lost
control of my life and made 12 different
flavors of homemade gummi bears
[Music]
is making your own gummy bears from
scratch kind of fun sure yeah but if you
do decide to make homemade gummy bears
whole wheat will lose you should be
prepared to confront a darkness that
lies deep inside you that you never knew
was there it all started when I learned
you can buy gummy bear molds from the
internet I had the Epiphany that you can
make a gummy bear that tastes like
anything you want you just add gelatin
literally anything can be a gummy bear
any drink can be a gummy bear any
cocktail can be a gummy bear anything
you can blend and a blender can be a
gummy bear and once you realize that the
world of gummy bears is basically
limitless you'll never be the same again
the main ingredient and homemade gummy
bears is gelatin gelatin is like having
a superpower you can use it for good and
evil with gelatin you can basically
solidify anything you want but it's
dangerous because while you can jellify
pretty much any food the question is
should you
so when it comes to gummy bear flavors I
thought I would start out with some of
your classic fruit flavors like
blueberry strawberry but I realized I
could do something like tomato juice or
a Bloody Mary gummy bear or even a bone
broth gummy bear or clam juice even why
not like if you really wanted to you
could make savory gummy bears I don't
know why you would but you could the
first thing I did was I went to the
grocery store and I bought all the
gelatin they had that's not an
exaggeration I literally cleaned them
out and I would eventually use it all
the process for making homemade gummy
bears is pretty simple you mix up your
liquid and your gelatin you put it into
the molds using a little dropper then
you just put it in the fridge for a few
hours and let it set but it can go wrong
my first batch of gummy bears which was
strawberry was a huge batch of gummy
failure on my first batch I only used a
little bit of gelatin and it made the
Bears weak and soft and kind of slimy
and no one's ever said oh I love gummy
bears but I wish they were wetter so I
needed to crank the gelatin way up
so once I finally got over my fear of
gelatin and used a bunch of it they
actually started to look like gummy
bears and my first batch of successful
bears that actually looked like real
gummy bears was a Manhattan cocktail
flavor
they had whiskey and maraschino cherry
syrup I wanted them to taste like an
episode of Mad Men and I feel like if
Don Draper tried these he would spit
them into the trash you asked me if I
liked it but I thought they tasted good
and he actually looks like real gummy
bears the most difficult part of the
process is actually taking the Bears out
of the mold you have to take each tiny
bear out individually and it takes
forever
once I nailed the formula I just kept
making more bears in new and more exotic
flavors and I couldn't stop there was
creamsicle there was matcha there was
coffee there was apple cider for fall
there was rose a there was even a
margarita there with tequila lime and
salt so a tiny voice in my head kept
saying maybe you should stop making
gummy bears now but I couldn't stop I
just kept thinking of new flavors I
wanted to try and I spent hours taking
little bears out of mold making gummy
bears I just I could not stop so I'm
almost too embarrassed to say how many
gummy bears I made I don't really want
people to know that this is how I spent
my time but I made a thousand gummy
bears
that's too many gummy bears I would
recommend homemade gummy bears probably
to no one but if you have a really
interesting flavor you want to try or if
you want to make a very slightly
healthier alternative to candy it's a
good thing to try but mostly you should
make homemade gummy bears if you want to
feel Howard
like the rules of tandy don't apply to
you and you want to make hundreds of
tiny edible bear friends do I think that
making homemade gummy bears was a good
use of my time
no but am I glad I did it sure why not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]